[Musique]
partenariat qui est vraiment innovant
donc 50 ans en Yvelines offre son
territoire comme un bac à sable on
déteste pour mobile eyes qui a la
capacité d'avoir des données
issues de ces voitures et qui nous
permet effectivement de pouvoir
identifier des zones dans lesquelles la
donnée va nous remonter les zones
accidentogène une déformation de la
chaussée
un trafic particulier et toutes ces
données là-dessus très pratique
ultra pratique pour nous exactement qui
servent puisque c'est du temps réel et
donc c'est vrai que nous on peut quand
on veut calculer le trafic on met
quelque chose au bord de la route et on
calcule le nombre de voitures qui
passent c'est pas très pratique c'est
pas très précis et on a du mal à
identifier les zones et surtout les
zones réelles donc c'est quelque chose
qui est très intéressant pour nous elle
rappelle justement on va savoir un petit
peu plus on va regarder un sujet qui est
consacré ce projet en compagnie de
Chaban kosavie qui est directrice de
performance data ça de mobile eyes
ambulance qui appartient naturellement
au groupe Renault
aujourd'hui les protocoles de mesure de
décratation des routes c'est des flottes
qui sont équipées de capteurs dédiés
donc c'est un protocole très lourd
maintenant imaginez que tous les
véhicules du compromis remontent
quasiment en temps réel la dégradation
de la route là où il roule nos véhicules
va opérer comme un capteur mobile
le partenariat entre mobile eyes et
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines concernent 5
services qui sont basés sur les données
des véhicules connectés combinés avec
les données de l'infrastructure nos
services vont opérer comme un diagnostic
vous traitez la sécurité routière la
réduction des émissions des polluants
une meilleure stratégie d'implémentation
des bornes de recharge la réduction de
la pollution sonore et enfin la qualité
de la voirie
30%
des accidents mortels de la route la
cause et le manque de la qualité de
l'infrastructure on va
identifier là où le manque de la qualité
de l'infrasse autoroutière et cause de
ce comportement accidentogène c'est à
dire j'ai beau être une conductrice
avertie je traverse une zone qui par
manque de qualité ou de visibilité ou
autre fait que je vais avoir un
comportement accidentogène
quand on vient récolter ces
problématiques de conducteur en les
projette sur le territoire pour détecter
là où en fait l'usager de la route a été
en difficulté on arrive à dire à quel
moment ils ont une par exemple besoin de
se recharger mais qui a pas eu de bornes
ou à quel moment en fait ils étaient
dans la difficulté parce que la borne
était trop souvent
occupée ou en panne
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours au Technocentre
Renault pour parler de la Smart City et
de cet accord mobile avec 50 ans alors
moi la data je pensais que c'était
quelque chose de très abstrait pas du
tout là je viens de voir avec ce sujet
c'est au contraire ça concerne tout le
monde et tout le temps quoi ça concerne
tout le monde et tout le temps là on
parle de la data public donc c'est
important de faire la différence avec ce
qui nous intéresse c'est le mouvement
des véhicules et non pas le mouvement de
Monsieur X voilà ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la possibilité de travailler au
service public et donc de pouvoir
remonter des soucis d'accidentologie des
soucis de ralentiellement
de façon à pouvoir c'est exactement ça
service public et donc data public
d'accord alors revenons à cette Smart
City alors évidemment les déplacements
la mobilité est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
domaines dans lesquels vous travaillez
sur justement ce concept de Smart City à
Saint-Quentin oui alors le concept
l'urgence c'était de développer
effectivement ces bandes de recharge
pour des véhicules électriques donc
Starsky que l'on a inauguré donc c'est
quelque chose qui est important ça nous
permet de récupérer de la donnée aussi
exactement c'était pour
générationnel et tu es pas là mon enfin
bon c'est pas grave mais il a pas voulu
que je mette la perruque d'ailleurs pour
pour le lancement on a on travaille
aussi sur l'éclairage intelligence c'est
quelque chose que l'on fait ce qui nous
permet de pouvoir répondre à une demande
importante de couper l'éclairage à
distance de pouvoir avoir un éclairage
qui s'allume automatiquement sur des
grandes voix et quand un vélo passe par
exemple donc on a à la fois la partie
environnementale et protection de la
nature et efficacité effectivement pour
les besoins de lumière et puis il y a le
plan d'Atel le portail de l'Open
d'attaque on est très fier d'avoir lancé
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
important pour nous je vous parlais tout
à l'heure de la la portance de d'avoir
la population qui participe à la
démarche le panne va passer ça c'est
leur donner la possibilité eux-mêmes
d'avoir accès à des données publiques et
de pouvoir travailler de pouvoir nous
aider à faire quelque chose de ces
données publiques là donc voilà il y a
aussi la pollution de l'air et beaucoup
de sujets effectivement sur 50 ans en
Yvelines sujet de Smart city on va
revenir justement sur cette pleine data
parce que pour montrer comme vous le
disiez que ça n'est pas réservé qu'aux
spécialiste
Saint-Quentin a ouvert récemment son
portail Open Data le 20 janvier dernier
c'est un portail qui permet de mettre à
disposition un certain nombre de données
publiques qui sont soit issus des
métiers de 50 ans en Yvelines dans ces
différents domaines de compétences
soient d'autres producteurs de données
comme par exemple des services de l'état
des ministères l'Insee l'hygiène ou des
fournisseurs d'énergie comme enedis ou
GrDF
[Musique]
ces données peuvent être consultées soit
directement depuis le portail sous forme
de tableau graphique ou sous forme de
cartes ou bien embarquer dans des
applications ou des sites web via des
API dans le champ des mobilités par
exemple 50 ans en Yvelines a développé
des bandes de recharge électrique qui
sont en train d'être déployer a aussi un
réseau de trottinettes en libre-service
le fait que le territoire pousse sur son
portail Open Data ce type d'information
permet ensuite aux applications de
mobilité de récupérer ces informations
là et d'avoir pour des utilisateurs une
information plus fiable et plus précise
on a mis en avant sur la page d'accueil
un jeu de données sur les consommations
et la production d'énergie au niveau du
territoire et ça permet de voir les
consommations depuis 2011 réparties par
commune ou par type d'activité on a
décidé de mettre un jeu de données qui
permet de voir l'ensemble des
établissements d'enseignements
supérieurs sur le territoire de 50 ans
de minuit classés par type de formation
quelles sont en alternance ou en
formation initiale par année
d'enseignement et par type de diplôme
donc ça permet aux gens de voir à côté
de chez eux quels sont l'ensemble des
formations disponibles avec des liens
vers des sites des établissements pour
pouvoir aller retrouver plus
d'informations
[Musique]
au-delà de l'obligation réglementaire la
volonté de 50 ans en Yvelines c'est
d'utiliser l'Open Data comme un outil
modernisation de ces pratiques et de
l'inscrire dans ces réflexions sur le
territoire intelligent et durable donc
comment utiliser au mieux les données
pour améliorer l'efficacité des services
publics mais aussi réduire des
consommations énergétiques on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment et apporter de
nouveaux services grâce au numérique à
l'ensemble de ses habitants
Bertrand coquin revoit que beaucoup de
domaines sont concernés par l'Open Data
mais le portail est très récent il a à
peu près un mois c'est ça absolument
est-ce que il va y avoir une montée en
puissance oui on l'espère on a déjà mis
à disposition effectivement un portail
de données mais également une
visualisation vous pouvez très
facilement sur la carte elle est
visualiser les différentes données qui
sont disponibles c'est important il y
aura une montée en puissance on espère
avec la nécessité pour les habitants de
d'acquérir ces données là de vérifier de
voir ce qu'ils peuvent en faire il y a
des applications qui sont intéressantes
où sont nos écoles pour l'attractivité
du territoire c'est quelque chose qui
est important oui là aussi avec la
participation des habitants c'est
absolument est-ce que ça peut être
utilisé en matière de développement
durable et de l'environnement oui alors
les données publiques sont très
importants puisque ça va effectivement
nous permettre en discutait tout à
l'heure d'avoir de savoir par exemple ou
on a besoin d'avoir des points de charge
de véhicule électrique on a parlé du
développement de ces bornes là ça nous
permet avoir des retours de personnes
Starski absolument sur le domaine
médical aussi peut-être qu'on en parlera
avec avec capteurs de
je dirais de la qualité de l'air c'est
quelque chose qui est important pour la
population et aujourd'hui c'est
difficile de savoir s'il est bonne
qualité ou pas parce qu'il y a ça varie
ça varie on n'a pas de données exacte
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qui apparaît ce sont des algorithmes
sont c'est pas des mesures précises
d'accord elles sont avec une précision
importante mais ce n'est pas les des
mesures bien précises justement il y a
des capteurs pollen je crois qu'il y en
a 12 sur le territoire de Saint-Quentin
et c'est une application qui s'appelle
live pollen qui donne de très très
nombreux renseignements regardez comment
ça fonctionne
la Smart City si on prend l'exemple de
la solution live pollen ça va pas être
que le capteur qui est une réelle
nouvelle technologie qui va réussir à
savoir quel est le pollen présent la
Smart City c'est aussi comment cette
information va être intéressante pour
l'habitant et va passer en effet par le
fait que la donnée elle va
instantanément apparaître sur le
portable d'une personne ou sur son
ordinateur et pouvoir via des
notifications directement l'alerte
[Musique]
le changement climatique va amener des
changements de pourcentage de personnes
allergiques actuellement 2022 on est à
30% d'allergies qu'au niveau mondial il
y a des estimations qui prévoit 50 % de
personnes allergiques à horizon 2050 et
donc on se dit justement comment on les
accompagne au mieux
[Musique]
chaque personne peut faire un petit peu
son journal de bord des des symptômes
qui peut avoir tel ou tel jour et ça va
être corrélé au pollen qui a été présent
et c'est vrai que pour aller voir son
médecin et autres ils ont leur petit
journal de bord pour dire bah j'ai eu
tel et tel symptôme sur des périodes ou
tel pollen était présent est-ce que
potentiellement ça peut être ça
[Musique]
on va aussi savoir la catégorie donc
est-ce que c'est des graminées plutôt
issus des plantes des herbes des choses
comme ça si c'est plutôt de certains
arbres et on va même savoir le type
d'arbres est-ce que c'est le boulot lol
ne le peuplier puisqu'il y a des
personnes qui vont pas être forcément
allergiques à tous les pollens pendant
l'année test on a pu constater que à
certains endroits de l'agglomération on
n'a pas des fois les mêmes types de
pollen sur la même période on a 12
capteurs sur le territoire on va avoir
là déjà on a certains pollens qui sont
présents sur certains capteurs mais pas
surtout
merci encore au Technocentre Renault
nous avoir accueilli à l'occasion de la
signature de ce partenariat entre
mobilize Renault groupe et 50 ans en
Yvelines Bertrand coquin on a on a
beaucoup parlé de Smart City de Data
donc on a l'impression que c'est des
termes de demain c'est déjà des tables
d'aujourd'hui mais est-ce que finalement
le visage de la ville va beaucoup
changer dans les années qui viennent oui
vous parlez de toutes les films de
science-fiction dans lesquels on voit la
ville modifier bien et bien non elle
sera modifiée par contre par la qualité
du service rendu qui sera plus rapide et
de meilleure qualité plus efficient
c'est vraiment le but de la Smart City
c'est pas de modifier la ville en tant
que tel c'est d'apporter un service
supplémentaire et meilleure qualité donc
faut pas en avoir peur absolument pas au
contraire il faut que les gens y
contribuent c'est la vraie démocratie
aussi c'est la démocratie de la data
c'est pas que dans les mains de peu de
personnes l'Open Data est là pour ça
pour répondre et donner cette
possibilité à chaque citoyen d'agir pour
sa communauté merci beaucoup et bon
travail alors merci beaucoup j'ai très
heureux effectivement que vous soyez sur
le territoire merci
[Musique]